الامريكية تحرك وحش البحار. فهل
هي حرب جديدة ولكن خلف حدود
لم تعلق بينما تايوان تحث ماسك
ان يوظف له مستشارا سياسيا. فهل
العسكرية. لتتهم الصين واشنطن
انها القواعد الاقتصادية
توقف ما تهدره هذه الشركات من
الغاز يعادل ما تصدره روسيا
اشباه الموصلات. وبعد ان فرضت
واشنطن قيودا جديدة على حصول
بكين. فتحذيرات الصين لا على بيع
الاسلحة لتايوان فقط بل ايضا على
الحبل هي ابلغ ما يصف وضع امريكا
والصين فتارة يميل الى واشنطن
مستقبلا. تصعيد كيم دفع الولايات
المتحدة للتنازل وتغيير موقفها
وحلفائها وهذا هو مبدأ كيم جونج.
الصين تقول كلمتاها. لعبة شد
والسلم. هنا رد كور والتي قالت
ان التجارب الصاروخية الاخيرة
حتى التاسع من اكتوبر الجاري بل
ويتعهد بتعزيز العمليات العسكرية
اطلاق هي السابعة خلال اسبوعين
بحسب ما افاد الجيش الكوري
السلمي معه اصبحت الصواريخ
الكورية كالدواء الذي يعطيه
وقد يكون الغاز الجزائري هو محور
الحديث فهل سترفع معدل انتاج
وهو نصب يخلد الجزائريين الذين
سقطوا في مواجهة فرنسا خلال حرب
الطبيب ليستخدمه المريض بعد كل
وجبة. وبعد ان اطلق زعيم كوريا
فرنسا? حيث ستقوم بومبي بوضع
اكليل من الزهور عند مقام الشهيد
الاستقلال بين الف وتسعمائة
واربعة وخمسين حتى الف وتسعمائة
ايتها الجزائر هنا رئيسة وزراء
فرنسا اليزابيث بون الى الجزائر
للجزائريين. لكن هل تكفي
التأشيرات للجزائر لتصفح عن
قتالية جديدة في سلوفاكيا. بوتين
يرد ويعقد اجتماعا مجلس الامن
امريكا والنرويج ليست الصداقة
الغاز لنا باربعة اضعاف سعره ذلك
لالفي متر من السيارات امام
محطات البنزين في ظل خروج محطات
تكن قويا لن يعترف بك احد. وبعد
ان استعمرت فرنسا الجزائر وادهبت
روسيا مستثنية اوكرانيا لتتفاعل
واشنطن بشكل ايجابي مع المقترح
التهديد يستمر والخطر يقترب اكثر
فاكثر. الناتو يعلن عن تمركز قوة
مصدر قلق للدول الاوروبية بل
تحول الى سبب لخلافات ومظاهرات.
لا يجسد المعنى الدقيق للصداقة
لم يعد ارتفاع اسعار الغاز فقط
الضعيفة يعيشون? ها هم يلاقون في
بلدانهم. هنا معاناة يعيشها
فهل انتم مستعدون يقولها
الامريكان? ومن التحضر للحرب الى
الفرنسيون في مواجهة ازمة الطاقة
التي تشهدها البلاد طوابير تمتد
سيارة ليخرج الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون. ويصرخ في وجه
والصين والى العالم اجمع. امريكا
تستعد للحرب بهذه القوة الخارقة.
سادة هي احدث ناقلة طائرات على
الاطلاق بقيمة تجاوزت ثلاثة عشر
جيشا سيبرانيا باستطاعته تعطيل
هذه الاقمار الصناعية وها هي
وتعمل على تحديد مواقع القوات
الروسية ليتم قصفها بوتين يمتلك
اوكرانيا بينما فعلها هذه المرة
فهل يريد ايصال رسالة للغرب
بالفعل تعطيل اقمار ايلون ماسك
التي كانت تخدم الجيش الاوكراني
حرب اوكرانيا. ويأتي قرار بوتين
هذا في واقعة نادرة. فالزعيم
فتحيم الجسر ربما يخلخل حاجز
الصبر لدى بوتين والذي اوشك على
المملوكة لايلون ماسك. وبحسب
تصريحات الجيش الروسي انه تم
النفاذ لكن لقد نفذ صبر بوتين
حقا. هنا صافرات الانذار لا
يريد ماسك ان يكون الاكثر جدلا
في العالم الاحداث والتطورات.
مجهولة. مخترقون يقطعون بث
التليفزيون الرسمي الايراني
سورية تستضيف قوات امريكية وقوات
محلية تعرضت للقصف من قوات
لحرب روسيا واوكرانيا اوائل ماسك
يقترح حلا لانهاء الازمة الصينية
العدائي. هنا تقول انها مستعدة
لاجراء محادثات من دون شروط
وتارة الى اصحاب العيون الضيقة.
هنا الامريكي لا يتوقف لتعلن
مسبقة مع بيونج يانج بشأن نزع
الاسلحة النووية من شبه الجزيرة
ويدعون الشعب للاحتجاج ضد المرشد
الاعلى. الولايات المتحدة
سرطان طائر في العراق بحسب موقع
بلومبرج. قال الجيش الامريكي نقع
شركات الطاقة في العراق تحرق
الغاز الفائض من الانتاج دون
التايوانية من خلال تسليم بكين
بعد السيطرة على تايوان. الصين
لاوروبا مشاعل الغاز هذه تشكل
ازمة تلويت للبيئة العراقية وهي
الجيش الروسي تعيين قائد جديد
لقيادة العملية العسكرية الخاصة
ومؤشرات استياء متزايدة في اوساط
النخب بشأن ادارة النزاع اعلن
التكتيكية في البلاد في الفترة
من الخامس والعشرين من سبتمبر
كامل. عدد الصواريخ في تزايد
والقلق الاوروبي يزداد. فمن يطفئ
الجنوبي. ها هو كم يقود تدريب
لوحدة العمليات النووية
الشمالية صاروخا باليستيا باتجاه
البحر صباحا واخر ليلا في عمل
واثنين وستين. فبما سيرد
الجزائريون يا ترى? لا حوار مع
الادخنة في جسر القرم تتصاعد
معها ادخنة التهديدات النووية.
احشائها الكثير من المتفجرات لم
يأخذ الامر من موسكو سوى بضع
والتجارية والاتفاقات الدولية.
وبين هذا وذاك وبعد اقتراحه حلا
غازها لانقاذ فرنسا ليكون
المقابل تسهيل التأشيرة الفرنسية
الصين على هذه المواد التي
تستخدم في تطوير اسلحتهم
اعتبروا اطلاق بيونج يانج
للصواريخ تهديدا خطيرا للامن
تأتي دفاعا عن النفس ضد
الاستفزازات وضد تهديدات واشنطن
واشنطن عن بيع اسلحة فتاكة
لتايوان منها متجاهلة تحذيرات
حوار مع الاعداء. امريكا
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبية
الكورية. رد الزعيم الكوري كان
موجعا وبقوة. اذ صرح قائلا لا
ساعات حتى اعادت ترميم الجسر
لتعود الملاحة فيه كما كانت.
الاعداء. هكذا قالها كيم متحديا
امريكا بعد ان رضخت وطلبت الحوار
منهم اكثر من مليون شهيد يتسائل
الفرنسيون. ماذا لو جئنا معتذرين
كثيرة عن الخدمة وتقنين
الاستهلاك بثلاثين لترا لكل
بحسب الصحف التركية. فماذا عن
فرنسا تحت رحمة الجزائر. ان لم
بوتين ليأتي الرد من تركيا التي
عرضت على الولايات المتحدة تنظيم
لقاء بين اربع دول غربية امريكا
وفرنسا وبريطانيا والمانيا مع
الروسي بانتظار قرارات مصيرية
بحسب المراقبين. فماذا سيقرر
بوتين النووي ها هو الوحش
الامريكي يغادر منطقة فهل هناك
اليوم معطلة بشكل كامل في
اوكرانيا. وبعد ان اختفى وحش
على عملية التفجير برغم ان موسكو
تحميه جوا وبرا وبحرا وقعت
الحادثة لكن الروس لم يتوقعوا ان
الهجوم سيكون بشاحنة تختبئ في
نراقبك? كانت اوكرانيا قد اطلقت
هذا التصريح قبل اكثر من اسبوعين
اوروبا تجد حل ازمتها في العراق
فكيف ذلك? وما الحل يا هذا? صراع
القوى العظمى. من هنا كانت
البداية? يا جسر كيرتش نحن
وامريكا تدعو كوريا الشمالية
للتفاوض؟ بينما الزعيم الكوري
عشرين عاما دون التزود بالوقود
في رسالة امريكية الى روسيا
استعدادات الشتاء الاوروبية. وما
جعل الغرب غيرهم من الدول
مليار دولار وتحمل اسم جيرولد
ارفورد البحرية الامريكية اطلقت
في المحيط الاطلسي. وتزن جيرلد
ارفورد الف طن بامكانها الابحار
موعد غرامي قد يجمع الوحش
الامريكي بالوحش الروسي؟ نعم يا
وشارك في حروب طاجاكستان
والشيشان وسوريا وها هو اليوم في
في اوكرانيا. انه سيرجي البالغ
من العمر خمسة وخمسين عاما.
على قصف روسي استهدف البنى
التحتية والجسور الرئيسية بشكل
منطقته؟ فهل يعد ذلك اعلانا
للحرب؟ وجيش بوتين السيبراني
الكوري لم يسبق ان كشف عن اسم او
هوية القائد السابق لقواته في
بذلك? بينما هنا القوات تبلغ عن
اعطال في ستارلينغ شركة الاقمار
بوتين بعدها هذا القرار العاجل
والمفاجئ يصرخ بوتين يريد مسحنا
غضب بوتين بعد سلسلة من
الانتكاسات المريرة على الارض
يريد مسحنا من على وجه الارض.
نعم. فقد استيقظ الشعب الاوكراني
وكما يقولها المصريون العيار
لميصب شييدويش. وعند تصاعد
تتوقف في كييب. الجميع يهرب الى
الملاجئ سيلينيسكي يصرخ. بوتين
اوكرانيا?
بوجه امريكا ويقول هل هذه هي
الصداقة؟ وهل هذه هي وعودكم لنا؟
ويلون ماسك يجد الحل وبين مجاعة
الفقر والازمة السياسية الخانقة
يخطب ود الجزائر وفرنسا اول
الواصلين. والرئيس الفرنسي يصرخ
يصدمهم بهذا الرد الموجع وبين
الصين امريكا. صراع الاقوياء
هما السبب. وقاعدة امريكية تتعرض
للقصف العنيف. فمن الفاعل؟ الغرب
يا جسر كيرش نحن نراقبك. اطلقت
اوكرانيا هذا التصريح ليطلق
من على وجه الارض ما الذي يحدث
في كييف والوحش الامريكي يغادر
يغزو اقمار ايلونماسك في
اوكرانيا بايدن السعودية وروسيا